edinboro is Scotland's financial center
the assets of Scottish banks located
there are higher than the country's GDP
but ninety percent of the bank's clients
are in other regions of Britain Brian
Stewart is very familiar with edinboro
financial industry until recently he was
chairman of standard life he's very
concerned about the repercussions if
Scotland votes for independence they
would have to relocate their head office
functions uncertain other of their
functions to England because they're a
sterling sterling denominated I think
that's almost inevitable I think
associated with that people just see
that as in a restricted context but
inevitably other functions would follow
that in terms of marketing legal
services etc Brian Stewart is certain
that if Scotland secedes there would be
many job losses in Edinburgh people who
work in the financial sector are worried
Brian Johnston works for the investment
firm brewin dolphin start with the
courtesy what cars are going to be using
we're going to use the pound if we use
the pond without permission who's going
to underwrite Scottish dead if we use it
with permission then we were hoping to
the UK to the English Treasury English
Chancellor English Bank of England so
where abouts independently yo yo so far
the British government has said it
wouldn't allow the Scots to continue
using the pound some financial
executives in edinboro believe Scotland
could switch to the euro there are also
concerns about who would be liable for
the next financial crisis at a major
financial institution it might also
constrain the willingness of banks to
lend in
got them because they simply wouldn't
have the reserve base say would add to
the degree of uncertainty that might
involve and of course the other issue is
we haven't got a sovereign bank in
Scotland like the Bank of England so on
prima facie we couldn't join the EU so
we couldn't rely on the support from the
culprit in that case Scotland's
Financial Services Authority doesn't see
any clear advantages by declaring
independence the UK is already a very
open economy we are part of the European
Union we have a very wide range of
international tax treaties and other and
other things which means that the UK is
a very open economy so we haven't been
able to identify any new markets that
would emerge from a move to independence
a yes vote on independence in Thursday's
referendum would require new regulations
for the banking sector an analysts say
it could take years to draw up rules to
guarantee real stability